chanson Colorado my wife and I paid off
our mortgage
we've been maxing retirement accounts
for years diligently saving in our kids
529 sword everyday millionaires at 31 or
41 and 38 way to go not sure where to go
from here in baby step 7
we're enjoying but are not sure how else
to invest for the future well Shawn the
rule of thumb is this it's almost like
we were talking about with that last
couple they said somehow among some
newly wealthy people there's a an ethos
this idea in the air that somehow
building wealth must be complicated you
must have some in the secrets of the
rich well let me tell you what the
secrets of the rich are they're not a
secret they do what you've been doing
they invest in things they understand if
you don't understand it don't put money
in it don't put money in something
because it sounds cool and some gube
that you think is cool is telling you to
do it or has done it himself
this is how people lose their money with
Bernie Madoff they got recommended by a
friend to get in something cool
there was an inside deal that no one
knew about it was a secret he was
sophisticated and everybody doesn't know
about it and this is how the rich do it
it's all behind the curtain it's just
not I was with a guy the other day who
is worth about 200 million dollars and
you know what he's invested his money in
farm land he's a rancher it's what he
knows I said you don't have any money
mutual funds of new don't like that
stuff don't understand it not putting
money in it well that's not
sophisticated Dave sent a guy who has a
tenth of the net worth or a fourth net
worth or one-one Julian the net worth
that that guy has he's got 200 million
dollars what you have an opinion put
money and stuff you understand and
you're comfortable with if that's all
you ever do you're gonna be fine as far
as the investing side I have three
investments that's all I have and I'm
fairly knowledgeable about the
investment world I have three my
business paid for real estate with no
mortgages and mutual funds I don't play
single stocks I don't screw around with
gold I don't mess with Bitcoin and I
don't need your stock tip from your
broke golfing buddy with an opinion you
know you missed out on getting you know
new steel rims you didn't miss a thing
I'll set my net worth down beside yours
while you mouth off didn't miss a thing
you didn't either
don't try to get so this is not time to
get cool cool didn't get you here
cool won't take you there and you know
don't try to follow these cool goobers
around because I got to tell you man
this this crap I see these things come
to the seminar and learn how to do a fan
you know a limited family partnership
with a double backflip trust and you
know I just made that up but it sounds
it's crap like that and people get all
tangled up in stuff and they lose their
butts don't do it don't do it so it's
real simple Shawn invest in things you
understand it's okay to use the KISS
principle I do I use the keep it simple
stupid principle I keep mine very simple
very clean and if I don't have the money
I can't buy it Wow it's insightful it's
primitive how do you get by on that with
a with hundreds of millions of dollars
of net worth that's how I struggle
through so seriously just be calm now
when you do get to baby step seven what
you do want to make sure you're doing
continuously and systematically is you
want to be keeping your spiritual life
in balance because maybe step seven is
where wealth can
take over your spiritual life and you
can put an idol in your life and you can
start worshipping dollars instead of God
and that's a dumb idea it's a good way
to lose your money because God will take
it because he loves you so much he
doesn't want you worshiping the wrong
stuff so how do you do that
you keep a good balance between three
things when you're in baby step 7
you're always investing you're always
being outrageously generous and I mean
outrageously generous you're in baby
step 7 you need to be giving more money
away than you used to make in a year
outrageous generosity and you need to be
enjoying some of the money time to take
mama on a cruise tightwad time to buy a
decent car you've driven like no-one
else now it's time to drive like no one
else
I drove crap cars one can one the
predominant color on it was bondo and
now you know what I drive any freaking
thing I want that's what I Drive now and
if some of you don't liberals don't like
that well Tuffy's I'm gonna do it anyway
I'm a capitalist Pig and I'm proud of it
so that's how this works guys and I give
more in a month than I used to make in
two years but that's none of your
business the only reason I tell you that
is it's a model for you to say
outrageous generosity our frame Z Family
Foundation is outrageously generous it's
so generous it has a full-time person
running it named Denise Whittemore my
daughter
it takes a full-time person to keep up
with the generosity think about it
that's where you can get to people
that's where I want you to get to you
can live like no one else so that later
you can live and give like no one else
and then when you go buy a car it's a
small percentage of your world these
people call me up in their car is 60% of
their take-home pay and a hundred
percent of their net worth you are never
gonna get rich doing that your car needs
to be a small percentage of your net
worth and a small percentage of your
take-home pay last
couple making seven or $50,000 they can
afford to drive very very expensive cars
and lose the value on them and still get
ahead financially but if you make
seventy five thousand dollars a year you
can't drive that same car and be
anything but broke she can afford a BMW
anything in the entire BMW line making
that kind of money
brand new write a check for it and it
won't break that family because they
make really good money they got a three
million dollar net worth but if you're
sitting there with two nickels to rub
together don't you go down there fleece
a stupid Beemer
that's dumber than a rock you're acting
like something you're not so you just
work your way through this process
always be giving always be enjoying a
percentage of your money and always be
investing a percentage of your money but
when I tell folks to do once you get to
this point is allocate percentages like
I just said basically I'm a cave
angelical Christian and I get taxed at
40% and then I give 10% so that's 50% I
give 10% just from my local church
that's my tithe
okay so I've only got 50 cents on every
dollar after those two things to work
with out of that 50 cents then I
allocate a small percentage to
consumption and enjoyment and then the
rest of it - two big chunks one to
investing and one percentage and I'm
gonna give you my percentages because
they don't matter you make up your own
okay but you take out that 50% that's
left over you put up you know some
little percentage it doesn't take much
because you make good money got good
money to enjoy go on a nice cruise go on
that trip you bucket list trip you've
always wanted to do buy that car you've
always wanted to buy pay off your mama's
house I don't know what it is you want
to do right then you take the generosity
pieces a big chunk and the investing
piece is a big chunk we cover all of
this in the Christian book that I did
called the legacy journey it's the only
book I've done that was aimed
exclusively at the Christian market
there's the only way I know how to
discuss wealth and it not become toxic
is through the lens of my faith so pick
up the legacy journey or take the class
if you're a member of financial peace
membership it's in the classes included
in there you take the legacy journey and
see
bit of this stuff I'm talking about and
you don't need a double backflip family
limited partnership this is the Dave
Ramsey show